ladies and gentlemen and to
point out
once again that last week we had to learn about terrible
terrorist attacks worldwide
the so-called islamic state has
claimed responsibility for attacks
in turkey in yemen in bangladesh and in iraq
this limitless terrorism and its
murderous ideology  can only be contained through
a strategy of global cooperation
would like to express our deepest sympathy to
the families, friends, acquaintances, the victims
and their relatives and their nations
on behalf of the european parliament
and
assume that the minute's silence
that we have just observed also
applies to these victims